there once was a boy 23 years old named
Elijah McLain Elijah McLain was a
sensitive boy he was bright and shy and
people loved him
they said he brought joy and lit up the
room with this smile Sherri Shepherd is
opening up about the death of Elijah
McLean the 23 year old man who died last
year after a confrontation with Colorado
police Elijah was walking to the store
one night to get something for his
younger brother he had his ski mask on
probably was so hopeful for the next day
the TV host sharing her feelings in an
emotional Instagram post on Thursday
talking about how Elijah reminds her of
her 15 year old son Jeffrey who has
special needs he wore a ski mask because
he had anemia so he would get cold but
it also helped him with this social
anxiety so that he could face the world
my son Jeffrey is an introvert as well
and things that are tight on him calms
his nervous system just like Elijah
McLain Sheppard then spoke the last
words Elijah was reported to have said
these words
Elijah's last words he said I can't
breathe I have my ID right here my name
is Elijah but claim I'm just I'm just
different that's all
it was announced on Thursday that the
state's attorney general will be
investigating McLean's death and
somebody reported that there was
somebody suspicious wearing the ski mask
and some police officers surrounded him
and they put him in a choke hold
Elijah died because nobody got to know
the beauty these cops you did take the
time to see what Elijah said that he was
different
Sheppard opened up to ET about how her
son Jeffrey inspires her
um and I do just really quick when I
talk to you
you look so awesome your weight-loss
journey has been incredible to watch why
did you feel motivated to lose weight
and change your diet let me see I think
I'm close to 270 days of sugar and I've
lost over I think it's probably like 30
pounds now but my son said to me when I
was eating a candy bar my son is 13 he's
got special needs and he said mommy if
you die who's gonna be my bodyguard and
I said what and he says who's gonna be
my bodyguard who's gonna take care of me
if you die
and that's when I went it cold turkey
and stop sugar because boys need their
mamas and so the perk is being able to
put on my little shoes and the little
jeans with the holes all in them but the
the biggest thing is I got my health and
I got my life and I get to enjoy more
time with my son
[Music]